so what's your plan mr. Guerra how would
you like to buy a bank what the hell do
we know about banking owning a bank is
like only on the other side of the real
estate business there's a few
complexities you just left out like what
oh I'm sorry
did I not wake up black this morning cuz
I'm pretty sure I did yep still black I
got my head full of dreams I came here
to try my hand at real estate you matter
millionaire unit you know the time
nervous I like seeing black men succeed
sometimes they even invest on my own
money to back I know you're smart and
ambitious
you're not both no that's not enough
it's time to someone shine a bright
light in order for things to change you
thought in a bad real estate at white
only neighborhoods be why now think
about all the good we can do for the
community for you taking it to the main
that's exactly what we're gonna do and
just how in the hell do you plan I'll
pull it narrow we get Matt to front
floors
you want me to what be us to the rest of
the world we can't set foot in the bank
best way to help took lemon wheel driver
when he had the chance I don't know
anything about banking I don't know how
to buy a bank will teach you everything
you need to know
you gotta learn how to talk to rich
white folks like you one up and you
can't fake a golf game make me proud son
fool country's talking about how to grow
managed by two banks full of white folks
money and loan it of enigmas you should
have known you couldn't keep this a
secret very long FBI you're under arrest
a black man tries to bring older
brothers up dacent our
Oh something's got to give
something's got to get him even a rigged
gang is fun to play but uh if this was
easy somebody else would have done it a
long time ago something's got you
revolutionary
[Music]
you
[Music]